bientôt diffusé aujourd'hui à steve jobs
simulateur on va être un [ __ ] de
cuistot by day ok c'est génial c'est
vraiment le meilleur jeu du monde je
vais juste mettre les petits plats dr
c'est totalement glauque ce qu'on voit
actuellement comment se chie dessus
ok les gars des partis j'ai attaché mes
mains ok ça va arriver ici alors on va
faire un petit break fleuve bacon et off
où je peux trouver du bacon et de l'oeuf
ça c'est fait donc on a dit en off et du
bacon de saaba on va pas se mentir of
césar 9 et oscar moins 9 du dinosaure au
on fait comme ça dans la vraie vie aussi
à temps ou là le foyer chaud très chaud
très chaud admettre tout doux et le
bacon bacon rio le bacon ça c'est le
bacon ça non [ __ ] c'est alors tout ce
qu'ils viennent nous on s'en fout on
veut juste servir dans les torrents
également comme la moitié des grecs de
paris on ans à bout les sépara poker
n'est bon voilà au attendait un petit
peu de poussière voilà c'est mieux
j'aime bien que ma cuisine et pourra pas
aller vers aussi bien le mec me direz si
ces moyens là vient la paper hockey
blender ouais alors cette cuisine est
révolutionnaire va pas se mentir il veut
un smoothie alors on va te faire un
smoothie mon pote du luxe on va te
mettre un fromage une pomme et une
carotte bon dans le doute va te mettre
une petite bouteille d'eau les ça
devrait être pas mal
voilà et voilà le smoothie est prêt on
le met dans l'assiette et on part sur
une sonnette annonce ici elle sait que
c'était mini comme ça je pourrais faire
un truc bien désolé alors pour le pépin
c'est bon je suis tu pars ok il eu un t
il veut un thé alors ici on a la petite
boule noire
on va mettre on va poser son petit
sachet de thé ici non non non on va le
poser ici on joue on va commencer par
mettre de l'eau la daurade et et je m'en
fais souvent donc si vous voulez chez un
peu comment faire c'est quoi ça c'est du
à
c'est tout ce qui est génique moi je
connais pas allez c'est parti
quoi attends et lui fait bouille mais
c'est n'importe quoi avec un an quand tu
as une théière tu mets ça sur des
plaques ne fait jamais ça ça n'a aucun
sens c'est comme si tu voulais tout
yellow direct comme ça alors qui est en
train de bouillir alors faut mettre le
thé dedans on se souvient où il est ça
c'est un petit repère mais moa dans une
tasse merde je tombais voulait aller
rechercher
ok on s'est brûlé au troisième degré
mais pour salaire ou déranger personne
ok aux maires non non non je suis désolé
attend on va leur faire on va le faire
on n'est pas des salloise pour un manga
ouai c'est réussi faut baisser une
poignée ouais ok ça change de frigo et
il veut du coup un petit biscuit
c'est super
non allez on va arranger ça là on s'en
bat les couilles
le petit cultiva avec le thé à ok il
veut les faire griller d'accord attend
là carrément mille trucs à faire c'est
beaucoup plus dur que d'être question
moi je conteste au [ __ ] bon ce sera un
peu entamée c'est pas grave on va dire
que c'est bon pour boire ok c'est parti
c'est pour toi moustachu ça m'a fait
plaisir
on va faire de la soupe faut mettre une
tasse dans la marmite d'accord on part
sur vraiment une potion harry potter
mais qui a manqué faut mettre d'accord
j'ai compris il faut mettre de l'eau
dedans
voilà [ __ ] qu'on est con mais qu'on
est con ensuite on peut mettre de tous
on va lui faire une vraie soupe quoi on
va pas se mentir avec ça ça c'est tout à
la suite de radin sa part sur youtube
d'or alors on remet ça à fond
attends-moi ingrédients brennus mais
qu'une fleur qui paraît que c'est
beaucoup mieux ok on est bon dans une
assiette
pardon un accord ça fais à un scandale
milhas en on a les boums sa part à la
fête - faire des trucs de de cuisine et
de vrais cuisiniers là s'il vous plaît
sandwich oui offert son oui c'est super
ça alors j'ai une [ __ ] d'idée on va
mettre une tranche de pain note marc une
autre tranche de pain et on lui faire ça
à ses fins il en faut quatre
pourquoi il en faut quatre ans aux
[ __ ] faut juste mettre là dessus donc
tous en bus est vraiment jugé scandaleux
je vais faire un sandwich vraiment un
sandwich au sandwich c'est vraiment un
plaisir allez tiens tu m'en diras des
nouvelles
quelle arnaque vita suivant et passa à
ok mais ils vont rester mais il ramène
sa propre viande
il veut juste finalement louis ces
plaques et veut quoi il veut du vin
assez bons il en reste plus tard annoncé
du bureau du hockey au super attend
j'adore ça beau allez c'est parti je te
serre ton petit verre de jus au shit et
c'est un [ __ ] de français c'est super
c'est notre pays alors il faut lui
mettre de l'argent en plus
mais pourquoi bleus mais qui vient
manger ici c'est nous qui le payons
c'est génial et un truc j'ai pas suivi
et la sppf russie allez c'est parti
clients suivants anthony sarthe
tony ça commence à mao cape town
américains ont black widow
ah ok pizza on va faire une pizza un
[ __ ] génial mais allez c'est parti on
part sur des tomates au matos suivant
sa totale avec un pouce à la gueule on
va mettre de la tomate sur le par à tort
fait à manger aux avengers mcfauld
totalement pas déconner micro wales ok
on met ça là on ferme la porte à mr
ferait toute chose avec d'accord ils
font comme nous le petit fromage râpé
google il le met carrément parapet aucun
problème la tomate avec et ça marche
c'est un sketch même possible j'y crois
pas une seconde mais non [ __ ]
j'aimerais tellement là ça dans la vraie
vie allégea bouffon voilà on va lui
filer une croûte qui voulait une belle
croûte
ce manque de respect pour l'avenger
spleeters des scandales alors c'était
bon allergique aux tomates une femme ok
j'ai compris j'ai compris j'ai compris
j'ai compris les allergiques à la tomate
mon psy a pas de problème wahou elle a
failli tomber tu as vu au pelage actif
c'est important que je ferme ça je suis
un mec qui fait plein de choses à la
fois on s'en bat les couilles la tranche
de pain on l'a fait sauter pour
impressionner le gamin on lui sert ok
donc tu veux juste une pizza avec ça et
un fromage dessus ah non pas du tout il
voit une pizza il veut juste ça
indirectement ben écoute on s'habille
bien un p'tit gars n'hésite pas à
laisser un avis sur tripadvisor pour que
mon resto nouvelle numéro 1 de paris au
revoir [ __ ] j'adore ce travail je me
fais chier allez c'est parti c'est
l'automne je sais qu'à chien la bague de
fiançailles qui tu verras qui m'offrira
sa copine dans son sandwich est super
aller il veut quoi il fait un oeuf avec
attend toi mon gars on va vraiment te
régaler boum
on prend l'homme au nom si l'on peut
faire ça aussi roma on peut faire cuire
l'os et met aussi la note de sanofi à
106 on arrête c'est bon c'est cuit la
bague à à ces minéraux mais j'ai tout
fait mais que ça a plaidé du monde
depuis 2000 - opus à l'encourager dans
sa connerie gamin de vanuatu fait et je
tuerai prévenu m'engage pas responsables
tu vas signer une décharge dix ans ce
super cuistot jenny m'a prévenu est ok
il a acheté un disque de musique
romantique qui veut que je pas elle va
s'étouffer en live mais que ça va être
un désaxé sur gvt à charbon futsal plus
loin c'est normal je fais un train de
mourir dans mon [ __ ] je viens de
brouter dans ma cuisine je sais que
c'est un vecteur mais c'est vrai je suis
en train de m'étouffer c'est un truc de
ouf en plus avec la crise est là et tu
bouges vraiment de vincent yvette quoi
aller c'était la parenthèse mature ok on
part sur un imposteur à temps mais c'est
important quand il veut que je grille
son disque pourquoi alors allez olla
s'en moque ok ce parti on lui met ses
parties planes
je vois là c'est vrai ils sont là bas
regardez le vieux boyard quoi
ils ont mis la bad
ils sont partis ils ont bien la vague
d'accords bomba au caire à les suivants
olalalala sa part sur un gâteau
d'anniversaire mon pote on a tendance à
suivre à la télé conneries allez c'est
parti
voilà faire en chantant celle là s'il
veut faire un gâteau sur par la fa c'est
la fin de cette heure ci sont aucun est
une tomate avec info matin avec des
motifs et la fleur la fameuse hausse
pouvez vous nous faire un gâteau à ok
faisons pas sonné elle en a marre d'être
maman elle veut se débarrasser de ses
fistons il n'y a pas de souci on est là
pour ça on est là pour aider le plaisir
d'offrir un segunda aux mecs c'est la
cuisine harry potter mais pour de vrai
joyau qu'est ce que je dois faire signe
c'est quoi ça mais non mais non mais ça
à ce que je voulais qu'il fasse la
vaisselle
[ __ ] j'ai vraiment pris pour ok ok ok
j'en suis là quoi j'en suis vraiment là
moi je me fais vie cause par des
employés c'est génial tiens tiens et ne
me parlent mais non mais non mais non
mais non mais c'est un sketch c'est une
dure fin de journée pour lucas au char à
voile à tien attention cactus fait
attention à moi mais je suis à fond de
cette vidéo sur le htc va cette fois les
petits cuistots annexion custom va pas
se mentir c'est un sauna plus et gagnent
n'hésitez pas même nos canaux mais le
suisse voulait venir manger un bout
nous restons n'hésitez pas il n'existe
pas à l'être la prochaine vidéo merci à
vous regarder portez vous bien